اسمي فِدا محمد، رسّام باكستاني
أنا رسّام
أنا مشغول الآن، سأتصل بك لاحقًا
بدأت الرسم في عمر 12 عامًا في باكستان
بدأت في الرسم وأنا لا أزال طفلًا
قال «أين فِدا»
قلت «أنا فِدا»
قال «أنت فِدا! اعتقدت أنك تملك ورشة رسّم كبيرة وأنت رئيسها»
قلت «الفرشاة هي الرئيسة»
ما تراه مناسب
نعم أحب الورد
أستغفرالله
احذف هذه اللقطة لاحقًا
لا جميلة اللقطة
سأرسّم على هذه السيارة
على سقف الشاحنة
أتيت من باكستان قبل 23 عامًا
يتحدث بالأردية
حين كنت في العاشرة
التحقت بالمدرسة حتى أنهيت جميع المراحل
ولم أكمل بعدها.
لماذا لم أكمل تعليمي؟
لأن والدي لا يستطيعان تحمل المصاريف التعليمية
التكاليف التعليمية عالية
منذ صغري لم أنم خارج المنزل قط
لا أعرف طريقة إعداد الشاي أو الغداء
أو طريقة طهي الأرز
أتيت للسعودية بدون عائلتي وقبيلتي
أنا أحمد الله عندما أفكر
لا أهمية للرزق ما دام مكة والمدينة قريبة مني
يحتوي فناء منزلي على أشجار كبيرة
وجبال شاهقة
ومياه الأنهار باردة، لا نحتاج للبرادات
هُنا نحتاج لمُبرد تجاري
وفي الشتاء تتساقط الثلوجي في قريتي
أنا رسّام شاحنات
كنت أذهب للورشة مع أبي
وبعدها أخبرته أني أريد أن أعمل في مجال الرسّم
الورشة في مدينة كراتشي
اسمها «حديقة كراتشي»
تأتي أفكار الرسّم في ذهني فأرسّمها مباشرة
بهذا الشكل ...
يأتيني الألهم، مثل ما يعمل الحاسوب
يعمل الحاسوب عندما تضغط على زر التشغيل
أرسم صقّر
لا يمكنني رسم الصقّر هنا
أنت الآن أصبحت مشهور
والجميع يأتي لتصويرك
هذا يتعبني أكثر
لكن ستصبح السيارة مثل«العروسة»
أن شاء الله
أنا أريد المال، لا أريد عروسة
هذه الدنيا... شاهد كلام الشيخ
صحيح؟
ممكن أبي أو أخي يشاهدون هذا الوثائقي
يقولون«ما هذا؟»
ثقافة السيارات الباكستانية
نهتم في الثقافة الباكستانية كثيرًا في تزين السيارات والشاحنات
فتكون شاحنته مثل بيته
كذا ستكلف مصاريف أكثر
هو يفضل أن تكون شاحنته
نريد أن تكون شاحناتنا عندما نقودها في الطرق مثل العروسة
«أطلها بالصبغة»
يتحدث بالأردية
أحرص على أرضا والدتك في الدنيا
حتى تكون من أهل الجنة في الأخرة بأذن الله
هذه هي الترجمة
يقول الله سبحانه«ماذا تريد يا عبدي»
أنت ماذا تريد
الله سبحانه يستجيب كل دعواتنا
عندما تأتي سيارة
أصحبها سعوديين أو باكستانيين أو يمنيين
أكتب على سياراتهم «صبر جميل»
يعني لا تسرع وكن صبور
القيادة المتهورة تسبب الحوادث
يقول الصبر جميل
«على كفّ القدر نمشي، ولا ندري عن المكتوب»
جميع الباكستانيين يتكلمون باللغة الأردية
«شعار وشير»
أرسّمها بطريقتي
فقط من أجلك رسمتها
فارس«الله يسعدك»
فقط من أجلك  فارس «شكرًا»
بسم الله والله أكبر
لا الحمدلله، ما زلت شابًا
اليوم الحّر شديد
فارس:«والله حّر»
بعدين أتحدث معه
لماذا لم تؤدي عملك بالشكل المطلوب؟
بعض الأحيان أضرب وبعض الأحيان لا
بعض الأحيان اضربه، وبعض الأحيان اقبله واطلب منه أن لا يكررها
بعضهم يطلب مني رسم نمّر أو صقر أو نخل أو عيون
أرسم حسب الطلب
أرسم نمّر حتى تكون سرعة السيارة مثل سرعة النمّر
فارس«لأن النمّر قوي»
هو يحب رسّمة النمر لأنه النمّر يرمز للقوة
أو يقصد بالرسّمة أنه قوي مثل النمر
هو قال أنا مثل الصقر
قال ذلك
اصبر قليلًا
لا لن يحصل لها شيء
أنا كل يوم أفحص فرشاة الرسّم
أنا أحبها
إذا لم يغسلها بعد الأسخدام أعاقبه بالضرب
لا مشكلة لدي في ضربه وتكسير يده، فأنا لا احتاجها
ولكن هذه الفرشاة رزقي
أحدثك من صميم قلبي
لا أحدثك إلا من أجل هذه الفرشاة
أنا أحبها كثيرًا
فارس «نعم»
اتركه
هنا؟
كيف؟ أجلس؟
عشان الصوت، تمام؟
كيف؟
يعطيك العافية
عشان الصوت أحتاجها